okay so McKenzie and Marcus yes yeah you
guys are you for me what I'm born and
bred in London Hampstead and I'm from
Leicester which is in the Midlands did
you guys know each other there or you
met here no we met in I was running
strip clubs in the West End and because
he came in as a dancer and that's kind
of how we originally met actually
and then I offered in many three ways to
come home with me and it eventually
worked right oh you know two is better
than one let's go back to your
childhoods you guys grew up in what kind
of families my family was very my dad my
dad was a licensee you know publican my
granddad obviously his dad was also a
publican to the same pub so he grew up
running that business and then actually
I actually kind of worked with him in
that for 10 years very normal business
like blue with like a white collar blue
collar which is it you know like kind of
middle of the road and a piece our
family yeah solid I mean can you not
religious couple even businesses in one
part one part London one partly in
Norwich just very very normal
honestly it's not like again well yeah
obviously I did you know but you know it
was never judged it was never an issue
it felt like I worked in a bank no one
gave me any stand still to this day
everything is amazing honestly that's
very nice so yeah I've been very lucky
so me on the other hand I come from I
have five sisters it's a whole logirl
from my mom and dad I'm the youngest of
the first batch which is how I like to
put it so my mom and I got divorced when
I was five years old so technically I
think my dad kind of raised me but he
had three jobs so it was a really home
so therefore it's kind of left up to my
sisters so there's me and then my oldest
is like nine years older than me and
then the other one ten years older than
me so okay I guess we were kind of kind
of a left to fend for ourselves a little
bit my dad works in hospitals he builds
hospitals a very normal family my mom is
I guess a housewife she's remarried and
whatnot which is how I've got three more
sisters so fairly no yeah no nothing
off-key like crazy like oh my god
nothing tragic happened to make me be
like some porn star or whatever it'd be
like oh my god I'm gonna go into porn or
whatever so you were working in a strip
club and you were managing it yep and we
we met there I was with someone at the
point I've been with this girl for a
poly nearly 11 years or more already and
it's she just said what you seduce
officer threesomes and yeah eventually
basically I started realizing they're
tabulation that I was iam wasn't really
it was just I was stuck in a rut with
someone that was great but it just
wasn't for me she was more exciting
obviously and we just end up get the
other woman ironically then I met your
ex-girlfriend yes and we are all friends
well it seems to me I think of the thing
these days I we're all friends so you
know so we got together and we were
smooth stripping for a good while I
think this is back in like 2000 I don't
think it's 2000 I think I started my
porn career in 2002 maybe yeah because I
basically the business I work for a
company called for your eyes only which
was a quite a big chain in the UK
Spearmint Rhino decided to come onto the
under the map in England and really
decimated the business you know they did
a lot of things that were not done so to
speak and of course it affected our
industry
you know our business itself and I got
this very despondent with my company
they weren't really aggressive and
making it work and the business started
to fail a little bit wasn't as good as
it was and I said you know what I'd been
doing
I'd done some porn I'd worked with some
big companies and I was like you know
what I can make you the biggest porn
star ever you've got the look you've got
the attitude as long as you listen to
what I tell you you'll be amazing and
literally contracts started happening
and working she was getting probably the
most money any girl was paid in the
marina scenes and and when we come to
the AVN you know Jenna liked her and
that was it everyone liked America doors
in the United States oh yeah yeah well I
guess like so what happened was I was
contracted to Playboy TV and play what
TV wanted to send me out here to do
Showtime
not as Michaels do Showtime for like it
was like for the AVN so they wanted me
to like host backstage for Showtime so
which is which is what open the door to
the whole Adrienne experience for me and
that's when I saw Jenna and I guess she
liked what she saw and then she offered
my then agent Marcus wheeler a contract
and then wicked pictures offered them
one at the same time so it's kind of
like who do you go to what do you do
I always think we show what a contract
was at the time so in the true so we do
just
well it was just you know the contract
men
you wouldn't work every day you would
probably shoot maybe eight movies a year
you do a bunch of photo shoots which was
great promotion and you would have that
title as you know Club Gino contract
star all wicked pictures contract star
which was a big deal back then contract
those were the rage hits Jessica James
was hustlers contracts done yes you know
it was a big thing and it really pushed
you to the top and then they got a PM
best new style of 2006 which was then
just where it just kind of took off from
that the industry has changed a lot
since I and my immense it's
unrecognizable in this way and she's
just come back in recently so I know so
I see the changes as in its massive like
now everybody shooting their own content
so you're technically your own you're
really your own boss and everything is
that professionalism down her honestly
to a point yes and the reason it's gone
down I don't mean that in a respect of
how you approach your job as a whole but
because these girls now can make so much
money from their mobile phone the odds
of them showing up to a set or
cancelling a set or just not giving a
[ __ ] is big now because they're making
ten or twenty grand a month on a phone
they don't need the $1,000 thing so they
will just cancel yeah I'm not coming
whereas before that would never happen
to be blacklisted you're not going and
you're done do you not I mean so I think
it's it's great for the performers us
because we are able to create our own
content make a lot of money without
having to wait for a scene to happen but
it's going to hurt the companies and it
hurts people to produce content because
the people just don't get
so where were the upsides and downsides
of being a porn actor you guys you guys
we're a couple you're no longer friends
yeahbsolutely - well we didn't speak for
a long long time not really because of
any other than she was with someone than
challenge like that wasn't because of in
general those four kids of outside
parties yeah fortunately really yes but
but you know there must be an upside
downside to being in relationship
difficulties free spirit when it comes
to his job like you know I see it very
like okay money-wise business-wise when
we first got in together he was having
his cake and eating it too like okay so
I remember even with us seeing with
Jessica I was like is this like whatever
it and he's all mine let me just check
around Twitter all right babe you know
that kind of thing lots of free spirit
when it comes to his love let's put a
like that flag around I'm definitely
more business as it like oh okay I'm
going to go here I'm gonna do that I'm
good on this is how much I'm gay pave
marks like in it for it good content
well you know iid after that emphasis
where if you're gonna do something
you've got to love it and to love it I
mean you have to really love it with or
without the money the money is
definitely a bonus don't get me wrong
it's a it's a bonus and it's the reason
I do it but I wouldn't want to do it
unless I really enjoyed it I just would
I'm not gonna force myself to do
something that doesn't feel right to me
so I just I guess my trick my mind in
into really enjoying it to the point
where maybe I get Aleppo and over
zealous over the top and that can affect
relationships traumatic yes like you
know so he's all over social media and
fine everyone's babe and baby like
you're like no let's step it down
you guys even get involved romantically
with somebody outside the industry or is
that just a possibility yes well it's
occasionally I've got friends that you
know I have a friend that's a was a big
porn star was married to a female bank
manager and they have kids and it works
great but on the other side it doesn't
work as well it really depends on the
individuals unfortunately I have been
with somebody that has not been in the
business and then it's more difficult
but they have their own fish it's going
on and sometimes it's kind of waiter
than what were in the business so it's
like you know and then I've been with
somebody also that I've completely give
it up for and I'm like you know never
ask me to just because I wanted to
because I felt like I needed to be true
to them to give them all of me you know
what I mean
so so it definitely affects
relationships this I think the biggest
problem with being a porn star and I
think what were you were saying about
you know the upsides and the downsides
is as a woman or as a guy you may get
with an individual that maybe isn't in
the business and then they see you in a
certain way they are maybe mesmerized by
the fact that you are a porn star in a
female sense for instance and they
expect things from you because of that
instead of it's just like I love you or
I want to be with you but ever they want
you to do crazy stuff because that's
what you do on camera which for anyone
that's trying to have a relationship
that's the last thing you ever want to
do you want to be way away from that
side of your life because that's your
job that's your work life this you want
normality and when that person doesn't
want no matter they want you do all
these crazy stuff you feel like you're
constantly work so that's difficult for
the women doesn't happen for the men so
much but that is definitely something
I've seen caused massive problems in
relationships with women with men that
we're completely bonkers even like some
of like some of the their scenarios
which they come up with are they even
crazy a little horn Senora and I'm like
and then they're all I world now you're
gonna say this and then they're gonna
say that and you're looking at I'm like
oh cool I caught three what somebody's
gonna say to me like how do we know that
like so it's this whole fantasy that
I've made up in the head but it's gone
way too far
yeah so
yeah so relationships in this industry
if you're in the business it's very
difficult and my best friend Tommy Gunn
will tell you the same it's mild
impossible to find something that works
because somewhere along the line maybe
may like it in the beginning but
jealousy will come in very soon and then
they'll all you're having sex on camera
I want to [ __ ] these people for fun
because you're doing it that's where it
goes tits-up I think sometimes you have
to like I mean what makes sense is to
stay within your own business because
that person knows that okay this is work
and this is working like each of each of
us know what's expected of each other so
when it's an outside influence like
somebody that really doesn't have
anything to do with this business
they've made up all these crazy
scenarios in their brain of what what
this is like when it's really not like I
think that's why Hollywood stars really
go with other actors because they're
involved in that world they know they're
gonna be away for three months doing a
movie and whatever and that's why people
stick to those a little puzzle
I guess that niche of this group of
people because they understand each
other yeah you know I mean I used to
toll here on what I'm doing mean I'll
see you tomorrow all right cool to
Amodeo and we'll get the end of our
alpha you know we're not eating after
six o'clock you know he already knows
the drill so but it's funny because and
I said this is a because mainstream
people nor civilians have this attitude
so if I walked in and saw my girlfriend
getting [ __ ] I'd be like all right do
want to eat but if she's walking down
the street holding hands of someone or
though I'd lose my [ __ ] check cuz
it's the flip that is normal but you
having feelings and holding someone's
hand and talking to that doesn't have
you know so we have the flip side of
life whereas most people go mad if they
walked in the store they go over having
sex but if their hard hats on their back
you know it wouldn't be a big deal so we
are the reverse of the of the civilians
if you think it's kind of strange it's
just good a lot our world is to sleep
flipped upside down it's like you know
did you guys have been in the industry a
long time you must have interesting
story depends what kind of
sharp me surprise me I don't know well
we there's this depends I mean there's a
dirty ones there like that the
disgusting side of the business I'll
give you that
so it picture this you're on a set three
guys one girl
it's an idol singer rough hardcore it's
not me but European this isn't an hour
by the way the owner seems going ahead
probably in a position where it's
causing a lot of air buildup in the back
Keith area vacuum guys got a very big
helmet pulls out creates a suction comes
out literally pebble - use the walls
shoe Logan place hits the floor girl
starts crying guy sees it throws up are
the guy slips in it forwards now making
angel wings on those [ __ ] and the
[ __ ] so you can imagine it's kind of
like a movie just that you wouldn't
believe could ever happen but that's
just a like oh my god that what happened
but yeah because you know this face it
doing an anal scene is one thing but you
don't really want anything else to
happen from that anal scene so when
anything does happen to that kind of
level it's not very pleasant so who
knows I mean anything can happen every
day you're gonna go in there anything
could happen it's just the act of God
that they know about you hope you're
hoping you're entering your to imodium
are really gonna save your ass
I literally remember when I should like
to go in the milk up my butt I shoved
two gallons Matt I got a little fall
with my feet so if someone gives me a
roll did I get a bit excited about it oh
my mates day I know dude let's shove
some milk on my butt and let Scott nails
[ __ ] out sounds good yeah so we go
above and beyond not the best idea Shep
the phone in my vagina and it rang it
was like the best service ever
so I think she's pretty crazy I'm
totally not that person but that was but
she was very hardcore I was very much I
did the romantic movies she did that an
insane movies I shoved snooker balls of
people but oh yeah we lost that one oh
yeah in Portugal that was always right a
few stories now of these really extreme
things they're pushing the limits they
really are pushing them see even today
like that yeah but today they're just
because it's sex has become a circus how
much you can do how much you can take
you know I loved the days honestly I
loved on porn I love the Tom Bowen days
with the beautiful girl walking down a
spiral staircase and the guys in a tux
plan a piano and this beautiful music
Shawn film that's what I like that's not
what we sell these days but then that's
why I'm not wanting to be around much
longer because it's not it's not the
world I came into he likes a Fabio world
of lying yeah you know one of me
I like the beauty side I'm not like that
I'm like you challenge me give me a
challenge let's go tell me I can't do it
I'll do it one better let's go that's me
okay so what we did stay together either
romantic or none no yeah very different
individuals that's that I don't want to
make I don't want to I would want to do
any other way I just don't want to do it
otherwise it's just no point there's no
feeling then there's no point to it
that's why I have a feeling they get
[ __ ] in the butt yeah but that's the
quite sick see what I'm dealing with my
gays just like different like just
challenge me please like I guess it's
like me in fencing I guess you just said
well you're an extremist you like
extremely like it you're the extreme
sports [ __ ]
I am the normal guy and you're the GoPro
sex
I'm the hassle bad I like just cool
quality and you like mad are fast and
crazy I want to see how much I can do I
want to push the limits that's it I just
you know if you can make me cry then
it's to be in the industry
doesn't mean that I think now what I
mean that the industry's changed so much
it's so varied you know from the fetish
side of things to you know the kind of
stuff she's talking about annual doesn't
seem to be as a bigger deal as it was
back now I'll be honest with her it's
nowadays unfortunately it's very heavy
into the incest I constantly work in
step out roles which I cannot stand mom
I hate it she always plays them off so
now porn is designed around niche words
for you know data tracking and all that
stuff to find that the porn you want to
watch and most of it is going to be step
toward daughter milf son that's
basically the most I mean I look at my
pornhub numbers I have 280 million views
on my porno 80 but I wanted where's that
coming from
so I'm looking you know at the things
that watch I don't that these gorgeous
movies that now I have done with her
I've done with wicked pictures 195,000
years and then I look up I come in my
step doors [ __ ] 25 million views that's
the state of the world now it's the
extreme stuff they want to see the weird
stuff that stuff that shouldn't be had
the taboos stuff effectively to boot I'm
very to be buried I'm in Tagaytay oh
she's gonna legalize that's my thing so
yeah like he always he always give me
[ __ ] for it oh yeah I just because I
think because I'm so I call myself the
vanilla porn star
you know they can watch your creep
what's your what's your thing I'm like
having sex they're like what you watch
thing you know I don't have a thing I
like contact eye contact beautiful girl
nice surroundings lovely music beautiful
lighting
leave me an hour together we're gonna
make magic if you can honest wish your
perfect scenario they knew a Miami
9 you're hearing it Oh like that was
like way more watching it all right well
you you watching it and then you've been
in it I didn't know how did you I'll
tell you about my dream the other day a
dream that I was in a bisexual corn was
what two guys are a with each other and
I was just like this and there wasn't
really sure what there if I'm gonna go
in the air and we're giving in the no
hope it wasn't it was not sexual it was
like kind of a boy at least but what
would you do in a scene what would you
want to have if you was to shoot a scene
now that would be exactly what you want
to be involved in what would it be I
always said that I'm gonna go out on a
massive transsexual gangbang and I
really think you know I really think I'm
going to do it like nope it's like there
are so many beautiful transsexuals out
there like there's so many beautiful
women out there though isn't it why go
that route you know but again like so
I'm saying there is something for
everyone
um envelope yeah I think that's how I
started my career I started my career on
it my second scene DP I'm gonna end it
like what about something crazy
I don't know I might like it stay in
because you know but that's definitely
my thing I'm definitely on there more
extreme and like pushing the taboo like
only because people say girls like me
you should not do that kind of thing no
I want to push that trying to envelope
and be like no just because you look a
certain way or you thought or you act a
certain way does not mean that
to be into these things that you say are
taboo what to me there are normal Friday
night oh it's funny because I remember
when we used to shoot together for club
Jana people would literally run out the
scene because they they just went for
the explosion because we didn't gel very
well as a couple in a sex scene we were
great as individuals but together in
scenes you know she would be like I'm
I'm having sex with her from behind and
she looked back at me with disdain and
go is that all you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm like a [ __ ] kidney punch you
[ __ ] is she's like [ __ ] like this
leave the camera by the pointer comes in
the walk-in at the door this is one of
the biggest companies in the world away
they go again well Michael always makes
this noise - no all right in every
single sexy lady does have you watched
it in my latest one out so like you guys
on this but I ain't annoys the [ __ ] out
I love it he does it and he ascends me
into like triggers I'm sure like I don't
know what are you doing like because we
had to work together reef and there
might people just please try not to do
it why did I do it but you're the grade
by now I'm trying to really intently see
you're looking for right now in show
you're looking I'm looking for it for
the past 15 years
watch it does it a little sloppy how'd
you go mostly i but I mean either makes
me laugh or it sends me into low end of
craziness so you guys I'm gonna give
each one of us hasn't liked it yeah
everyone else we do thing that we do
when we're like not really thinking cuz
I'll brain just goes there like I think
mine is oh it's so good
well you know that the problem is with
porn this is what I hate about it is
it's like we have been given a glossary
of words that we constantly use over and
over again which I hate I'd rather gag
the girl so she doesn't I don't say
anything I whisper and a girl here I'm
talking about what I'm doing see the
trick of dirty talk is basically giving
someone the
playboy play-by-play of what you're
going to do what you want to do and
you're saying it in a certain way to
make it very sexual very very
stimulating to someone in the mind so
that's what I do you know whereas a lot
of people they fail this fall stuff like
I hate it when I go goes [ __ ] me with
that big dick I might have you seen I
don't have a [ __ ] big dick I hate
that wines not what a girl says that I'm
just like it's annoying it's like it's
not real be will just say [ __ ] me I like
the way you [ __ ] now I like the way you
feel because it's a poor thing cuz it's
all about big it's good when but when
you get on set with girls and they say
it could pick it they're like oh [ __ ] do
you find the outside world
judges you guys because once they find
out the area of the industry I'll be
honest I don't think we've had that
problem because was so blatantly out
there were they think that you like it
or you don't
I spoke to one agent and he says he goes
on a cruise he has to say that he works
in tech or something like that just like
just to kill the conversation from going
oh you were in porn funny I've never if
I've ever said I've always said I never
lie about what I do and it's never been
nothing but positive ever probably now
especially because I think this day and
age people are very enamored by the
feather Wow never make me one or tell me
more about it I've got so many questions
never anyone I go never had that once
maybe that's because I'm a guy you know
because if a girl said it to another
female maybe that would be shunned upon
it's fun it's funny how it's different I
mean I don't think I have many I have a
few like close female relationships I
don't have a ton of them because they're
not going to explain myself here like it
explained why the things you know and to
me I can't have a friendship with
somebody without them knowing they are
so I am not ashamed of my past like I'm
not ashamed of wipe-down no shame no I
still do it's just my life
you know and I would like to I don't
know it's like even though I have two
children
- I'm gonna I raise them to be very
open-minded about a lot of things even
though we have definitely not touched a
subject yet they're alone they are 11
and 12 I teach them that love is love
and like definitely we'd like you know I
guess one of my daughters came home the
other week he said that there was a
there's a boy in her class would like to
be a little girl so I was like oh this
is happening earlier these days no so so
we touched you on various subjects and
and definitely love these love just not
matter what sex you are or you know who
you identify as love is love and it's
the same feeling with your boy boy go
girl whatever
yeah so it's a it's definitely
interesting tell me I mean the thing is
what I'm notice about the porn world and
what I derived from being important is
people watch porn for a lot of reasons
some of it's obviously sexual
gratification but honestly a lot of
they're male as well as female some
point is they want to learn maybe they
think they're not doing something right
so they're trying to use porn as kind of
like a learning learning platform which
unfortunately is the wrong place to look
it will give you some pointers but most
of it will be disinformation because
everyone thinks most men think you got
to have a big dick now I've been around
16 years and I have definitely am NOT
within the realms of some of the guys I
know and I make more women come than
later
hands down no question it's been my
specialty 50 years so it's not a problem
if you're not big but what is a problem
see if you don't know how to make a
woman feel good but God is how you do it
whether it's your fingers your mouth
your hands whatever if you don't add a
tree or a rock right in the bedroom and
outside of the bedroom it doesn't matter
what you're packing it's not gonna be
any use to you and I porn
gives this terrible thing or you got
throatfucking for hours you got power to
the degree pound them to the ground and
kids these days are watching that and
that's what they're going out and doing
and their girls are like and even girls
that think that you know I'll pick up a
girl for instance if I was going to be
with a girl and she'll try and
[ __ ] me I'm like
[ __ ] are you doing its recurrence
there's no need for I don't like it
it doesn't work then I doesn't feel good
I don't like it I'm a blow job was
supposed to be sensual slow and eye
contact that's what they're supposed to
be easy time and you should tell high
but you know porn is giving this very
bad perception of what sex supposed to
be what you're supposed to be which it
isn't supposed to be necessarily I gotta
say that's one of the things I'm moving
into is not sex coaching men in a sense
of doing big seminars and telling them
exactly how it's supposed to be done
we're not swinging from the chandeliers
and we lived we lived I had lived in a
ranch with Tommy Gunn
my wife definitely at the time to other
porn stars another guy and everyone's
like oh man I'm like yeah we go bed at 9
o'clock after we hope Spartacus and
they're like what you don't have orders
I'm like no it's like they just got this
incredible that we're just a crazy group
of people we're actually probably more
nor more than the flower guy running the
flower shop down the street yeah we go
get tested every 14 days
oh and legitimately healthy very very
and we're pretty boring very boys come
out on my now I'm staying with dogs
tonight I'm watching this really good
new show on Netflix and we're not
chilling all right guys thank you so
much for talking to me you're very
welcome thank you thank you yeah it's a
good boy oh I guess a poem I can do dice
it off I know stuff I was I'm not even
close
oh great it was perfect tasted
everything yeah yeah the more bonkers
one oh yeah she's